G
ABORTIONS BECOMES MORE LIMITED
EVEN WHERE ABORTION IS LEGAL.
>> STEPHANIE AND HER HUSBAND
DAVE ALWAYS WANTED A BIG FAMILY.
A SIBLING FOR THEIR DAUGHTER
HARPER.
SO WHEN THEY FOUND OUT STEPHANIE
WAS PREGNANT WITH A BOY LAST
SUMMER, THEY WERE OVERJOYED.
>> THIS WAS A VERY WANTED CHILD.
WE PLANNED FOR THIS BABY.
>> BUT 12 WEEKS INTO THE
PREGNANCY, AN ULTRA SUND
REVEALED A BIRTH DEFECT WHERE
THE FETUS' INTERNAL ORGANS WERE
DEVELOPING OUTSIDE THE BODY.
THIS PHOTO SHOWS A DEFEATED
STEPHANIE THE DAY SHE RECEIVED
THE TRAGIC NEWS.
>> WHAT WOULD THAT HAVE MEANT
FOR EQUALITY OF LIFE FOR THIS
BABY?
>> THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN NONE.
HE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SURVIVE OR COME HOME.
>> STEPHANIE WAS ALSO TOLD HER
OWN LIFE COULD BE IN JEOPARDY.
AT 19 WEEKS SHE AND HER HUSBAND
MADE THE PAINFUL CHOICE TO
TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY.
>> AN ABORTION IS WHAT I NEEDED
TO SAVE MY LIFE AND GIVE MY SON
THE DIGNITY THAT HE DESERVED.
I COULDN'T CARRY THIS BABY TO
TERM AND HAVE MY HUSBAND HAVE TO
BURY BOTH OF US.
IT JUST WASN'T AN OPTION.
ABORTION WAS.
>> THEIR HOME STATE OF NEBRASKA
ALLOWED ABORTIONS UP TO 22
WEEKS.
BUT THEY COULDN'T FIND A CLINIC
THAT COULD SCHEDULE THE
PROCEDURE IN TIME.
AFTER A DESPERATE SEARCH ACROSS
NEARBY STATES, THE FAMILY
SETTLED ON THE BOULDER ABORTION
CLINIC IN COLORADO.
>> DR. WARREN HEARN HAS BEEN
PROVIDING ABORTIONS FOR NEARLY
HALF A CENTURY.
HE'S 84 YEARS OLD AND REMEMBERS
THE DAYS BEFORE ROE V. WADE.
>> THOUSANDS OF WOMEN DIED EVERY
YEAR FROM UNSAFE, ILLEGAL
ABORTIONS.
I THINK ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS DECISION IS THAT WOMEN
WILL DIE AS THEY DID BEFORE ROE
V. WADE.
>> IN COLORADO, ABORTION IS
LEGAL AT ALL STAGES OF
PREGNANCY.
EVEN BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT'S
RULING LAST WEEK, COLORADO'S
FAMILY PLANNING CLINICS WERE
STRUGGLING.
>> THIS IS SORT OF AN ABORTION
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT.
WE GET PATIENTS FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY WHO CAN'T BE SEEN IN
OTHER CLINICS.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE THAT IMPACTING
THE SURGE OF PATIENTS COMING TO
COLORADO?
>> SURE.
SO IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO
EXPAND THE SERVICES.
YOU HAVE TO FIND THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL DO THIS AND RISK THEIR
LIVES TO DO IT.
>> AS ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY WHO PERFORMS LEGAL
ABORTIONS LATER IN PREGNANCY,
DR. HEARN SAYS HE HAS SEEN HIS
PATIENT LOAD INCREASE 50% FROM A
YEAR AGO.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT
SAFE ABORTION IS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE
IN THE 21st CENTURY AND THAT'S
THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
NO WOMAN'S LIFE AND HEALTH
SHOULD BE AT THE MERCY OF THE
NEXT ELECTION OR A ZIP CODE.
>> HARPER STILL ASKS ABOUT
OLIVER JAMES, THE NAME THEY
PICKED OUT FOR HER WOULD-BE
BROTHER.
>> I HAD TO TELL HER THE BABY
WAS TOO SICK AND THAT BABY
WASN'T GOING TO COME HOME WITH
US.
AND THAT SHE WASN'T GOING TO GET
TO MEET HER LITTLE BROTHER.
>> HIS ASHES, HAND, AND
FOOTPRINTS ENSHRINED ON THE
LIVING ROOM SHELF.
>> WE VERY MUCH WANT ANOTHER
CHILD, BUT WHAT IF THIS HAPPENS
AGAIN?
WHAT IF I HAVE ANOTHER HIGH-RISK
PREGNANCY THAT PUTS MY OWN LIFE
AT RISK?
I DO WANT ANOTHER BABY.
AND NOW I'M SCARED TO.
I WAS SO EXCITED AT THE IDEA OF
A POSITIVE PREGNANCY TEST.
AND NOW IT SCARES ME.
IT SCARES ME.
BECAUSE